[Applauso]
[Musica]
toni pagone giudice presidente
dell'associazione internazionale i
giudici la magistratura pensiamo a
questi tempi complessi instabili nella
società nella politica nell'economia è
sempre un po vista da l'impressione di
essere quantomeno una forza stabile un
punto di riferimento come dire una una
forza in qualche modo è davvero così
importante che dà l'impressione di
essere una forza stabile da un certo
punto di vista ovviamente lo è una forza
stabile e che infatti deve essere però
le devo dire che come giudice
c'è una grandissima vulnerabilità nel
lavoro che uno fa come giudice una
vulnerabilità personale è anche una
possibilità istituzionale cioè i giudici
lavora tipicamente da solo cercando di
arrivare alla decisione regarde moi che
disputo tra litigante non è per niente
facile
1 e dei dubbi le cause che vengono
portati in corte sono tanti dove non è
chiaro cos'è la risposta se è uno o
l'altro perciò scuro hai dei dubbi si
deve fare delle lotte in sé per vedere
cos'è la posizione risultato giusto
inoltre sono tantissimi cambiamenti nel
mondo che creano degli altri
vulnerabilità cioè la legge cambia
rapidamente stiamo parlando qui di
farcela leggi cambiano rapidamente in
tutti i settori
il giudice deve essere mantenuto
corrente a questi tutti questi cambi e
non è facile devo dire per per esempio
il ramo fiscale con questo google tasks
che è stato introdotto in vari posti ci
sono state ovviamente tanti cambi nel
modo di andare e organizzarsi
commercialmente che ha dovuto creare
delle
nuovi basi su il fisco e giusy deve deve
aggiornarsi in questo nuovo campo non è
per niente facile
anche la tecnologia anche la tecnologia
infatti io se posso evito la tecnologia
anche se anche io c'ho la tecnologia
però c'è la tecnologia che crea dei
nuovi problemi etici che uno non aveva
pensato nel passato per esempio facebook
seguono pensa soltanto alle cose che uno
mette su facebook e poi pensa delle
probabilità delle possibilità che quello
che volo mette incoscientemente sul
facebook viene poi essere usato in un
qualche modo contro l'intento di quella
che aveva fatto una cosa è complicata e
importante l'indipendenza della
magistratura in un mondo che cambia così
rapidamente
io direi che le dipendenze della
magistratura è molto più importante dato
che stiamo facendo
questi grandissimi cambiamenti infatti
tutto questo che noi stiamo parlando del
fast five del cambiamento rapido è
possibile in parte perché sappiamo legge
che sono prevedibile quando 1 tappa chi
tasso ed importante che si può prevedere
quello che si fa
ed è importante che se c'è qua che
disputo tra le parti che voleva da un
giudice e il giudice della una decisione
indipendente dalla volontà umana
perciò questi faccenda una da un punto
di vista sono soltanto possibile se c'è
una magistratura indipendente che
applicano delle leggi che sono obiettivi
a proprio tutti quanti ecco indipendenza
legalità rischiano però di essere
concetti astratti perché poi alla fine i
giudici sono persone sono uomini sono
esseri umani come si combattono i
pregiudizi
beh ci sono dei vari tipi ci sono
specifici e pregiudizi
per esempio può avere pregiudizi banale
come qualcuno che ti fa
diciamo non solo il momento sì invece di
milano qualcosa così ci sono altri
pregiudizi reverse però che sono più
importante più difficile più
problematici per esempio il peggio di c
riguardo al sessismo e razzismo
e questi periodi ci sono progetti che
uno deve scontrare in qualche modo deve
levare fuori dal conto che uno fa quando
fa la decisione questi pregiudizi una le
sconta in gran parte insistenza che ci
sia la decisione fatte dai giudici
referendum si legge obiettivi che
esistono fuori dal dal giudice è perciò
il peggio di città quei tipi di
pregiudizi vengono tolte in gran parte
perché vuole deve dare ragione e
motivazione giustificazione nel rendersi
alle leggi obiettivi e non la volontà
personale
però devo dire che ci sono la ta serie
di pregiudizi che sono molto più sottile
e molto piu difficile c'è adesso una
buona grandissimo studio in nel campo
della psicologia cognitiva che studio
dei pregiudizi che uno a senza sapere
che uno lea per dare un esempio
diciamo un banale pro reale se una norma
contempla che ci sia
diciamo la sentenza basato su una misura
di mesi invece una misura di anni per
esempio 36 mesi invece di sé a tre anni
di tempo è uguale sempre che il giudice
quando deve imporre una sentenza
rendendosi
e si impone sentenze più bassi di quelli
che f1 imposti se uno le mette su
periodi di anni di giudizio si può
vedere si può calcolare purtroppo esiste
e ce ne sono tantissimi
tra l'altro questo è un pregiudizio che
vede anche quando fa fare shopping
se uno va in negozio e vede non solo
tappeto turchese che scontato da mille
euro 50 che vende il grande affare si da
quando e perché ha deciso di diventare
un dice beh allora nel sistema mio in
australia 1 non ha la scelta di fare la
carriera di giudice sinda finita la
scuola e dell'università
da noi uno che è richiesto viene
nominato dal governo
normalmente a quelle che succede a una
certa età volte verso gli anni 50
infatti io ero imparando qualcosa però
quel periodo io avevo fatto una diciamo
una bella carriera principalmente nel
ramo del fisco i ragazzi si erano
cresciuti li avevo portato di cisco ciò
per me c'era due motivi principali per
perché avevo accettato la proposta di
diventare giudici quando mi è stato
chiesto in parte mi chiamo filosofica
era aveva avuto questa buona esperienza
e mi sembrava il tempo di dare indietro
qualcosa alla comunità cioè che era una
buona cosa da fare di essere i giudici
vuol dire fare decisione portare avanti
le regole della comunità e chiedere una
cosa buona da fare l'altro visto era
personale nel senso che era interessante
il lavoro del giudice indubbiamente
interessante le cause che una nave erano
interessante occupava la mente ed i
fatti mi ha portato tra l'altro anche
qui raccogliere una sfida insomma darsi
sempre degli obiettivi se in tale chiedo
ancora questo come vive la
responsabilità di prendere delle
decisioni che poi hanno effetti
dirompenti magari definitivi sulla vita
delle persone
ovviamente parlo soltanto per me ma
penso che quello che dico giusto anche
per tantissimi dei miei colleghi
io l'ho sempre considerato come un
grande peso avendo una responsabilità di
fare delle decisione avendo effetti
reale effetti sulle persone euro un peso
che per me occupava molto tempo molto
pensiero un peso però che veniva
allevato in parte pensando come era il
caso che applicavo delle leggi che erano
resistevano al di fuori di me cioè legge
che non avevo creato io
leggi creato dagli ha tagliato qualche
volta anche leggi che non mi piacevano
però dovevo applicarle perché quello era
la legge e perciò era un peso che potevo
in parte sollevare dicendo beh io devo
applicare la legge doveva applicare una
norma che esisteva obiettivamente fuori
di me e mi cercava di fare una decisione
che siano stati ben ragionati bentrovati
così
dalla morte non era situata gli assicuro
cosa bella risposta provano provava al
massimo detti essere giusto senta
ultimissima domanda è questa qual è
l'insegnamento sopra tutti qual è il
messaggio che lei intende lasciare a chi
ci ascolta qui e oggi mi sembra che è
abbastanza chiaro il messaggio
principale per tutti quanti che ci
ascolta oggi se uno vuole avere il fast
chains che continua è necessario avere
una forte giulia magistratura che sia
indipendente che si occupano di
applicare la legge che porta esistono
oggettivamente al di fuori del personale
altrimenti il fascio non può continuare
se vogliamo fast change è essenziale che
le leggi siano prevedibile che uno può
anticipare cosa sia il risultato è che
vengano applicati da magistrati che sono
indipendente di interferenza fra sia
degli altri parte che del governo da
altri persone questo essenziale
altrimenti il fas change non continua
grazie fani pavone
[Applauso]
[Musica]